a lot of children that are misbehaviors
are could possibly be conceived doggy
style or that how a child is conceived
could then determine how it behaves in
Life or how a person behaves
because I've definitely seen some of
them
um them dsbs maybe them doggy style
babies and they uh they're often up to
no good so missionary conception if you
want more of a passive child I believe
but also what the [__] do I know bro I
actually have some anecdotal
verification of that one of my children
was conceived doggy style the most
anxious child you have ever met okay
so exhibit a right there this lady's got
that dsb
you know she had that doggy style baby
right there man I can't that's wow it's
wild to hear a woman that is brave
enough to admit it and I commend you you
know you either straight up Amelia
Earhart of being on your knees right now
you're you're brave enough to admit that
you uh conceive a child doggy style and
I respect that and I respect you young
lady let's hear more
my other one was not and he is chill as
hell they're they're two years and two
days apart they are the same
it's just weird when you said that I
lost it wow
proof baby
this is proof right here son you know
what I'm saying
call me Arthur Conan Doyle bruh we're
making real evidence right here all
right call me um
you know Daniel Day Lewis son you know
uh who else Socrates baby we got it we
got a little bit of evidence thank you
for calling with this evidence young
lady
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one